Check out the "Play the Road" app...
...created by Volkswagen and British electronic music legends "Underworld."
This app turns cars into your own personal DJ on wheels.
It makes music directly to the beat of your drive.
Accelerate and you might hear some fast-moving drums.
Make a sharp turn and maybe you'll hear cascading scales.
The app uses data from the car's on-board computer...
...and even uses GPS to play specific sounds.
Drive through the countryside, for example,...
...and you'll hear birds in your personal soundtrack.
You'll have to wait a while before becoming your very own composer.
VDubs is worried about safety implications,...
...so it's not yet available for commercial use.
Still, it gives a whole new meaning to "pedal to the metal."